el dorado reactiva sus operaciones
durante cinco meses el aeropuerto
internacional más importante de colombia
tuvo que cerrar a raíz de la crisis
sanitaria mundial muy probablemente no
vamos a tener vuelos de placer los
primeros días pero sin vuelos de
necesidad hay mucha gente que tiene que
ir a hacer diligencias a otras ciudades
que tiene que venir acá hacerse un
examen médico que tiene que visitar a un
familiar que esté enfermo pensemos en
todas esas personas que a partir de
mañana tienen una opción rápida y segura
de conectarse el cierre del aeropuerto
permitió intervenir en su sistema
operativo con el fin de darle más
seguridad a los pasajeros antes de
viajar el registro se hará
obligatoriamente en línea a la llegada
las personas registran su equipaje sin
ayuda del personal cuando no supere los
23 kilos todos los espacios son
desinfectados antes y después de la
salida de cada vuelo cámaras térmicas
tomarán la temperatura de cada persona y
habrá otras que controlarán el
distanciamiento social los aviones
cuentan con el señor check-in avalado
por la organización mundial del turismo
y con el cual las aerolíneas se
comprometen
y todos los protocolos de bioseguridad
con la reapertura del aeropuerto
internacional eldorado los colombianos
ya tendrán la oportunidad de viajar a
algunos destinos que fueron aprobados
por el gobierno nacional 80 vuelos
fueron autorizados en este primer día de
reapertura y ya son 8000 los pasajeros
confirmados tres elementos clave para el
inicio de operaciones tiquetes
económicos flexibilización en el cambio
de fecha sin ningún costo y también el
uso de nuevas tecnologías que antes no
habían el ambiente dentro de las
aeronaves era como en una sala de
cirugía el aire se renovará regularmente
para una distribución eficiente y por
ahora el cupo no será completo para los
vuelos nacionales la reactivación de
eldorado va de la mano con la de otros
sectores de la economía pero es claro
que la pandemia de kobe y 19 dejará
cicatrices muy profundas en la industria
aeronáutica